هل من رد فعل روسيا على زياره بايدن منذ
قليل الى كيافا
يعني
ربما في تصريحات الخارجيه هذا الامر لم
يذكر بشكل صريح وان كان ذكر في البيانات
السابقه ان مثل هذه الزياره انما تستهدف
تصعيد الصدام المسلح الجاري وان عمليه
الدعم لحكومه زيلينسكي وامداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه ومعدات العسكريه
وعمليا تصعيد للصراع الدائر وتوسيع لرقعه
المعارك وايضا رفض لي اي استئناف
للمفاوضات السلميه بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
الامر الذي ترى فيه موسكو عمليا تدمير
لاوكرانيا بشكل كامل وفي نفس الوقت تهديد
لمصالحها القومي طيب هناك نقطه اخرى كما
اشرنا هناك نتحدث عن اتهامات من قبلات
المتحده للصين تحديدا هل من رد فعل روسيا
على التهابات المتحده الصين بتزويد روسيا
بالاسلحه
يعني رد فعل الرسم لم يصدر حتى الان ولكن
من المعروف رئيس مكتب لجنه العلاقات
الدوليه في الحزب الشيوعي الصيني قد وصل
بالفعل الى موسكو ومن المتوقع ان يلتقي مع
الرئيس
سيكون لا شك ان الملف الاوكراني حاضرا في
هذا اللقاء ولكن الملف الاساس بحسب اوساط
مقربه من الكرملين هو الاستعداد لعقد قمه
صينيه روسيه في موسكو الربيع القادم بحسب
العديد من خبراء في موسكو لا شك ان تعاون
الصيني الروسي في مختلف المجالات وخاصه
للمجال العسكري يقطع ويتنامى خاصه وان
الصين اصبحت شريك اساسي في المناورات
التدريبيه المشتركه التي تقوم بها القوات
الروسيه سواء في امام قباله سواحل جنوب
افريقيا التي كانت منذ ايام قليله او في
المحيط الهندي او في المحيط الهادي
بالتعامل مع الهند الى اخره ولكن في نفس
الوقت هذا الفريق من الخبراء يرى ان لدى
الصين مصالح مع الغرب وان حجم التبادل
التجاري
فلسطين مع الغرب يفوق تبادل التجاري على
الروسي الصيني بعشره اضعاف او اكثر
وبالتالي هناك توازن توازن دقيق لدى الصين
في اطار التعاون والتنسيق مع روسيا
وان الموقف الصيني حتى الان الرسمي المعلن
هو عمليا عدم التورط او التدخل في هذا
الصراع الدائر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ودعم ايجاد سبل لتسويه سلميه لهذه الازمه
ويعلل هذا الفريق من المراقبين هذا الموقف
بانه محاوله لارضاء كافه الاطراف وايضا
لتهدئه هذا التوتر الامر الذي يحقق
المصالح الصينيه ليس فقط في روسيا وايضا
في اوروبا شكرا